welcome to the newshour we begin with
warnings of an attempted coup in armenia
the prime minister nicole paschanian has
fired his military chief after the army
called for his resignation
he says that call amounted to a coup
attempt
and is urging his supporters to gather
in the capital yerevan
he's been facing protests and calls to
step down
robin forrester walker is joining us now
from tbilisi robin what more can you
tell us about the situation in armenia
well nicole pachinyan is hoping that
he's going to be able to pull out
large numbers of armenians to
republic square in the center of yerevan
which is where all demonstrations in the
past were
first in support of him uh when he came
to power a few years ago
uh in the so-called velvet revolution
now he's in a political
uh struggle of his of his life um
having said that the statement
issued by the armed forces the general
staff of the armed forces of
republic armenia calling for his and his
government's resignation
amounted to a military coup so um
when he when he went on air a short time
ago addressing the armenian public on
his
facebook page in a facebook live he
actually on air
dismissed the head of those armed forces
and now is waiting for more people to
arrive on republic square where he will
uh make a public address uh at four
o'clock local time
yeah robin and i believe we're looking
at uh the latest pictures
uh from uravan where people seem to be
converging on the square so it'll be
interesting to see how many people
uh come out and what will happen next
[Music]
yeah some of them we've been hearing uh
chance uh
in support of nikola pachinyan saying
nicole pachanyan is the prime minister
um he is the elected prime minister he
came to
power um with a landslide victory in
elections a couple of years ago
and his tenure was all about reforming
armenia making
armenia more democratic uh getting rid
of the old
system the old politicians who were seen
as a
corrupt and authoritarian but of course
the war in karabakh last year
was a devastating uh defeat
for armenia he signed a humiliating uh
peace treaty with azerbaijan brokered by
russia
armenia lost all the territories
surrounding the
enclave of nagorno-karabakh in
azerbaijan
and now they're a russian peacekeepers
on the ground
um and a huge humanitarian crisis as a
result
and armenian uh forces lost more than
three and a half thousand
servicemen um which is a huge number
for such a small nation there are still
prisoners of war that have yet to be
returned
and there have been anti-government
protests in armenia
as a result of this humiliating defeat
calling for nicole pacquiaon to stand
down
but it's got to be said that the
opposition
that have been coming out in recent
weeks calling for mr pacquiao's
resignation
may or may not have the kind of support
needed
to be if you like the legitimate uh
new face of armenia because uh it's
based on polls and based on public
opinion that i've seen
mr pacquiao may not be as popular he as
he was he may
have lost a lot of support but he may be
uh
the the the best the country uh
considers
there is to to offer when it comes to
the armenian political situation
and he has so far resisted calls for
snap elections but that may be what's
necessary for him in order to
confront his accusers and to finally
show
who in armenia has the authority to lead
this country
after that appalling defeat in the
nagorno-karabakh conflict
last year yeah okay robin thank you so
much for that update from tbilisi well
just to pick up on what robin was saying
armenia has experienced political
turbulence in recent years
the opposition leader nicole pachanian
was elected prime minister by parliament
in may 2018
after leading weeks of mass protests
against the ruling party
in december 2018 he called a snap
election to remove the republican party
majority in parliament
his my step alliance won an overwhelming
majority
the republicans won no seats and
passionian promised to maintain
armenia's strategic alliance with russia
but he faced calls for his resignation
in december 2020
after agreeing to a moscow brokered
ceasefire
with azerbaijan let's now speak to
richard guerra gosian who's the director
of the regional studies center that's an
independent think tank in the aravan
armenia he's joining us from there
thanks for your time with us
on the newshour and just to um pick up
on on russia because we are getting some
news lines this is according to the
reuters news agency where the kremlin
is saying that the events in armenia are
exclusively a domestic
issue there but russia will no doubt be
looking at the situation in armenia with
some interest
richard gregosion can you hear me
yes welcome to the newshour what do you
think
russia's next step may be or or
reaction right now the reuters news
agency is reporting that the kremlin is
saying
events in armenia are a domestic issue
but the russians will be looking at the
situation closely as it unfolds
well clearly i think russia is now
measuring its response
on the one hand russia is in a
precarious position
because what we see as robin has
outlined
is an unprecedented risk an escalation
that actually threatens to implode
within the country in terms of a risk of
a military coup that is unprecedented
in terms of the russian military and its
close support for the armenian armed
forces
this is one driver of moscow's response
but in contradiction to that russia has
long ago decided to keep its support
investing in the armageddon government
and prime minister pashinya
what this means going forward however is
the real risk of escalation is
rooted in the prime minister of
armenia's overreaction
in terms of calling supporters into the
street
is not necessarily a wise move for an
institutional democracy
and i think russia is correct yes this
is driven by domestic determinants and
drivers
but the real test will be on the streets
of armenia itself
and i'm greatly worried because over
three dozen
senior officers have joined the call
demanding the resignation of the prime
minister this
is a real challenge and test of
institutional democracy
yeah here's the thing we're looking at
the live pictures right now coming out
of the streets of yerevan not sure if
you can see them or not but that is the
prime minister and he's
uh leading the the protesters who are
marching
behind him he of course had made that
call for his supporters to come out onto
the streets
how much support do you think pashanyan
has right now is it possible to kind of
engage his support in the country
well i think your correspondent robin
was very correct
the prime minister and this government
have diminished popularity
but the alternative the discredited
political opposition
has much less support so in general
there's little alternatives
to pashinyan or his government but this
is unprecedented in terms of a military
threat
to the government much greater and more
grave
than anything the discredited and
unpopular political opposition could
mount
what do you mean by that what are you
basing that assessment on
well in terms of the political
opposition being overly
dominated by the old government by the
corrupt former ruling government which
is widely discredited
and it is very difficult for them
because they're unable as an opposition
to
offer or propose any alternative in
policies
and again it's politics by personality
rather than policy
and with the successful
non-violent revolution in armenia in
2018
farcinon and his government are still
able to count on
a core base of support
so what happens next there was the the
the prospect
raised uh by passionate himself actually
uh of early elections to be held this
year i mean is that the way forward
i think it's the only way forward we
need a fresh mandate an early election
to begin to resolve and defuse
a pre-existing political deadlock in
crisis
legally and constitutionally this is the
only way forward
in effect reflecting the new post-war
reality
all right we will leave it there thank
you so much for speaking to us from
yerevan we appreciate your time thank
you
thank you